hey everybody how's it going today I'm
going to show you how you can program a
Honda Accord key uh to work with your
car so today I've got a 2009 Honda cord
now this pretty much works with all
modern Honda cords um if you've got the
key then you're all set if you got if
you got a key like this then this will
work they all pretty much have the same
concept so um what you want to do is
first of all I I'm going to change this
key this is an old uh key that's broken
and this is the original key that came
with this car but unfortunately it's
broken so you're going to need the
original key or just the key a key that
you use with your car that's going to
turn the ignition um and you're going to
need this of course so you probably have
this already and I bought this from eBay
I saved uh
around 180 bucks buying this this was
for
$14 um and it's not copied yet but I'm
going to go to Ace and they're going to
copy this for me and uh Hey I'm going to
save around 180 bucks just doing this if
I go to Honda and they copy the key and
program it for me I'm going to have to
spend
$200 which is a total waste so I'm going
to do it myself and I highly recommend
you guys do it too so anyways we're
going to go ahead and program this so
all you want to do is you want to grabb
your original
key and then you want to go to your
ignition and what you want to do is you
want to insert the key in there all
right so what we're going to do is we
are going to turn the ignition on to
number two so if you see right there
there are numbers so this is zero one
two and three three will turn your
engine on two will turn your radio and
your uh pretty much your AC on and one
will just put your car in
standby uh but it will not as you can
see there the time the timer is on but
the radio is not on um so uh actually
the radio is on but the AC is not on so
if I go to two it's going to turn on the
AC and the
dashboard so what we're going to do is
we're going to go on to number two and
we're going to do this every time I'm
going to turn off the AC so what what
you want to do is you want to press
block you see that
led now go
back go to number two
again
Lock close the
car go to number
two
Lock close
this now you want to go back to number
two
lock
close the
car go to number two
again you see that you guys hear that
the car just locked so I'm going to lock
it and then I'm going to open
it as you can see there we just
programmed this for
free so we're going to step out the
car and it's
nighttime I'm going to close
this
and we're going to get
close and we're going to lock it using
this new key let me just focus this
so lock
it you see there just locked the car
with the new
key we're locking the
car so there you go very easy to do very
very simple you've got a new Pro
programmed key for free anyways if you
enjoyed the video be sure to rate
comment and subscribe and uh I'll see
you guys in the next one
peace